I know that the phrase "sentinel chickens"
does sound a bit ridiculous.
These chickens here in Griffith,
in rural Australia,
are not keeping watch for anything.
They're not on guard.
They are just... chickens.
But they are helping keep folks
in this area of New South Wales
safe from some nasty diseases.
Diseases like Murray Valley
Encephalitis, MVE.
It infects animals,
including humans,
and it's carried by mosquitoes.
It has no vaccine, no cure.
Most people who get it will
suffer fever and nausea,
but about one in a thousand
will get seriously ill,
with a chance of life-changing
brain injuries, or death.
If that virus is starting to flare up
in the animal population around here,
mosquito transmission means
it can easily spread to humans,
so it'll be really useful
for the local health department
to have an early warning system.
- We have eight flocks at the moment,
and there are 15 birds per flock.
They are usually between 9 and 14
weeks old when we get them,
at the start of the season.
They are fed, watered
and they lay eggs.
And that's an additional bonus for the
person that's looking after our coop.
They get to keep the eggs.
- Ideally, the researchers would
track levels of the virus
in wild animals and birds.
That's where it thrives.
But that plan involves catching
and testing wild animals.
Not practical.
So instead, chickens!
They don't get sick from MVE
or other diseases like it,
and they can't pass
it on either.
But if they get infected,
their immune system
still fights it,
still creates antibodies.
The technical term
is "seroconversion".
And these chickens are outside
every hour of every day,
and the mosquitoes will
bite them a lot.
- We take a small amount of blood
from each chicken, weekly.
They collect the chickens,
and then we do a bleeding process
where they take a small amount
of blood via a lancet
from under the wing, collected on
a small blotting strip.
It's just a very small pinprick.
The chickens have a leg band on,
so that we know very specifically
what bird and what sample,
and we can match them up.
And that goes off to
our labs in Sydney
where they do a number of tests for
a whole range of mosquito-borne viruses.
The mosquito levels are
important as well,
but it's not enough
just to track mosquitoes.
It's important that we monitor
a reservoir
that can give us a
better indication, quicker.
The chickens give us a
pretty early warning,
within a couple of weeks.
If we saw seroconversions
in our flocks,
we would ramp up the local media
to get that message out:
use a repellent, not be outside
at dawn and dusk,
and wear light,
loose-fitting clothing.
Camping groups,
fishing groups,
those people that are visiting areas
get the message as well.
We'll provide information
to local GPs
so that they will be
looking for symptoms.
And there are other flocks
in other countries, I'm sure,
as part of their
surveillance program.
- Of course, once a chicken has
tested positive, its work is done.
It will always have
those antibodies,
it will always test positive.
So at that point,
it is retired,
and I'm assured that's
not a euphemism,
and testing continues on
the rest of the flock.
I was a bit worried about
animal safety and cruelty here, but...
Do you mind?!
...the chickens are well cared for!
They're just having a blood sample
taken occasionally.
In a world with factory farming
and fried chicken shops,
this does seem fairly low down
on the scale of
"things humanity
does to chickens".
- We really have no other way
of knowing what virus
might be around in the area.
And they do save lives.
- Never work with animals(!)
Th- This is not food!
These are my fingers!